the real meaning of geralt's new armor a
hilarious meta joke dumping on season 1
and mysterious witchers from the past
everything you missed in the witcher
season 2 just ahead
as a dark fantasy series it's not
surprising to see twists on fairy tale
motifs in the witcher the first episode
of season two adapts and borrows the
title of one of the series most popular
short stories a grain of truth and
features a dark love story reminiscent
of the classic fairy tale beauty and the
beast however the beast in the witcher
is cursed after doing something much
worse than being mean to an old woman at
his castle door a grain of truth shows
geralt and siri meeting with nivalin who
has been cursed with bore-like tusks fur
and claws after he sacked a temple and
assaulted a priestess all curses have
cures
what does she say
she screamed something about
love and blood
nivolin is hiding another secret from
geralt his vampiric lover verena lives
in the abandoned castle with him and has
been feasting on travelers who get too
close
varena is a brooksaw a powerful creature
who drinks blood and can turn into a
giant bat geralt fights farina but it's
nivalin who steps in and stabs the
brooksa to protect the witcher and the
princess
this act of blood and love breaks
nivolin's curse and he returns to his
original human form
as season 2 of the witcher prominently
includes vesimir it was bound to have
nods to the witcher nightmare of the
wolf the netflix anime that describes
vesemir's origins and the brutal attack
on kermorin though witcher's age slowly
vesimir is considered the oldest among
them the anime shows how he becomes a
mentor not only for geralt but also to
lambert eskel and remus the four young
boys who escaped the battle at the end
of nightmare of the wolf in the witcher
season two we finally see escalant
lamberts all grown up and in live action
remus meanwhile appeared in season one
but was killed by a striga as part of
siri's education vesemir explains a bit
of the history behind karamorin and
witcher's abilities he tells her about
fighting and living through the attack
on caremorin in which humans and magic
mutated monsters assault the stronghold
in an attempt to eliminate the witchers
we also see the massive tree in the
middle of karamorin's hall where the
medallions of fallen witchers hang
outside of karamorin's keep bones of
humans and monsters still litter the
ground
including a massive skeleton that looks
like it could very well be from the
mutated griffon that attacks vesimir in
nightmare of the wolf
in the episode 2 scenes that are not set
at caramorn we follow a beat up and
broken down yennefer who is captured by
nilfgaard forces after the battle of
saturn hill she reunites with former
classmate frangilla a sorceress on the
side of nilfgaard she also meets with
francesca an elven mage who is a leader
among her people the three mages enter
some ancient ruins where they eventually
find an illuminated straw house that
begins to move on spindly legs inside
each of them meets a version of the
depthless mother a character created for
the series who serves as a mysterious
antagonist throughout season 2. while
this storyline is not part of the books
the house on stilted legs and the traits
of the deathless mother parallel
elements from the witcher 3 wild hunt
video game the house in particular is
reminiscent of the slavic legend of baba
yaga a mythological character who lives
in a straw cabin that roams around on
chicken legs in the witcher 3 the trio
of witches known as the crones are
loosely based on the tales of baba yaga
as well the deathless mother is also a
bit reminiscent of baba yaga as she is
shown shape-shifting into different
people based on which mage she is
interacting with while the witcher
series on netflix is based on the
stories and characters from the books
both seasons still include subtle nods
to the wildly popular video games season
2's second episode titled caremorin is
all about series education and training
there in one scene vesemir gives siri a
little tour of kare morin's vault which
prominently features weapons and armor
from past witchers the scene focuses on
two gleaming swords which dedicated fans
might recognize from the witcher 3 wild
hunt video game the top sword is the
viper sword a silver sword recognizable
by the snake on the pommel and its
unique bolt-shaped cross guard the
bottom blade is steel and belongs to
geralt in the witcher games witchers
typically carry two swords a steal one
for fighting non-magical beings and one
coated in silver to slay monsters
besides geralt yaskir the bard is one of
the most popular characters in the
witcher series oh aren't you just the
cutest
most
terrifying thing i've ever seen in my
entire life run away run away girl in
season one geralt and yaskir part ways
after an explosive argument that sees
geralt blaming the bard for all of his
recent woes
however yaskir isn't doing so bad in
season two as he has developed a new
look and sound that hearkened back to
his portrayal in the books and games
in these scenes yaskar is also sporting
longer hair an unshaven face and new
attire that is much more in line with
what he wore in the books and games
along with a purple-hued leather coat
one brief scene shows him crooning while
wearing a hat with an egret feather in
it bringing back one of his most
memorable accessories
the witcher second season is largely a
grim affair but there are some moments
of levity thanks to the musical stylings
and commentary by yeskir the bard when
we first see yas gear in episode 4 he's
belting out his newest ballad an epic
breakup song with the hook burn butcher
burn it's angsty emotional and
hilariously recaps some of season 1's
adventures with the witcher from
yaskir's perspective it may not be as
catchy as toss a coin but it brings some
comedic relief to the season one
memorable scene shows a man telling yes
gear that his niece is a big fan of his
work but he also has a few pointed
critiques for one of yesgear's
a bit complicated it took me to the
fourth verse to understand their
different timelines
this is of course a hilarious and
self-aware nod to the convoluted
timelines of season one the witcher
creators have been upfront about changes
to the structure of the show for this
season showrunner lauren schmidt
hissrick participated in an ask me
anything on reddit in 2020 where she
detailed how season 2 would be much less
confusing for those who were thrown off
by season 1. second season geralt grunts
much less than he did in season 1. a
trait the witcher himself henry cavill
said he pushed hard to change per
gizmodo that doesn't stop yes gear from
hilariously poking fun at geralt's grunt
in season 2 saying that geralt's grunts
and he makes a song we wonder how geralt
would feel about that
doesn't rhyme
by the middle of season 2 you'll notice
geralt has fashioned himself some shiny
new armor this new armor made out of
thick plates and leather is both
imposing and allows geralt more
flexibility while fighting monsters in
addition the new armor also symbolizes a
key evolution in geralt's character and
philosophy in a release from netflix
cavil said he had a big hand in
redesigning the witcher's new armor
which made it easier for him to move
around and fight throughout the creation
of both seasons cavill has been open
about his love for the witcher franchise
the books games and show and about his
influences on making changes to geralt's
look and character through all 16
episodes geralt's new armor isn't just
about the character's mobility in the
same release cavill explained that this
new armor symbolizes geralt's comfort in
remaining in one place for a longer
period of time
typically geralt is a loner on the move
with no opportunities to fashion new
armor however the time he spends in
karamorin with siri eskel and lambert
shows his belief in the safety of the
witcher stronghold and his trust in his
fellow monster hunters
in episode six titled dear friend a very
pregnant francesca walks with frangilla
in the gardens of sintra the two
sorcerers have become friends and
clearly care for one another but have
very different goals
while frangela serves nilfgaard and the
mysterious white flame francesca's chief
concern is the safety of her unborn
child and her people the elves while the
two walk francesca stops to bring some
white roses back to life and picks a few
for her baby's bassinet she also tells
frangilla about discovering her magical
powers following the death of her mother
with whom she loved to pick flowers in
the book blood of elves white roses are
symbols of the elven heroine elerin also
called the white rose of cherowin arylan
is best known for leading a last
desperate battle against the humans in
the books white roses still grow at the
ruins of sherwood and francesca's
revitalization of the flowers is a small
nod to elerin's sacrifice
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]